military and they're both
from somewhere else
is there any evidence that the cattle
mutilations are
because of the government that the
government instigates them in some way
well that's a long long story i
i i mean
asap did not do any investigations of
cattle mutilations there were two
uh there were two aspects that we
decided
um and the defense intelligence agency
decided we would not spend a lot of time
and resources actually three of them uh
one was the remote viewing that i've
already discussed the second was the
calamus mutilation phenomenon
and the third one was we we decided
not to
recruit a whole team to investigate uh
ufo of quote unquote abductions because
again that required an enormous amount
of
resources that i know that we knew at
the time were not going to be available
so cattle mutilations were not
investigated by the uh the osap program
but um back in the national institute
for discovery science era
we actually did a lot of forensic
investigations
of
cattle mutilations and again i refer to
the ned's website which you can find
by
googling national institute for
discovery science
uh on wikipedia
and there are dozens of reports
of ned's investigations of calculations
on i will cut to the chase basically and
say that
we
literally investigated dozens of
mutilations how do we investigate these
we actually had full-time veterinarian
on our staff
vet veterinarian who was also a phd in
pathology so who was well used to doing
necropsies uh you know animal autopsies
and so
our our sort of bottom line was that
cattle mutilations
there was a body
of evidence that was lying on the ground
and if we could get to that
that body quick enough after death that
we might be able to get some answers
so we evolved over many years a
situation where we had a bunch of
veterinarians who were accredited
veterinarians on call we had a bunch of
police
officers throughout the western states
in the united states
also on call so we were able to get um
reports of cat emulations
extremely quickly and the third thing
that we had was that we had a menu
of laboratory
uh analytical laboratories
on call on speed dial
so that if we did manage to get samples
we would we were able to do
histopathology analysis we were able to
do chemical analysis biochemical
analysis and you know uh pretty well all
of the different analytical frameworks
so uh we were pretty well equipped at
the end of ned's to be able to
investigate cattle mutilations
and what we found was that there was
a really two two two types of
mutilations
once one was the standard sort of
mutilation where the uh the eye the ear
uh the uh sex organs uh were were
removed from the animal
and you know during that situat that
that uh
program for for nis
we did a lot of analytical chemistry we
did uh elemental analysis of the blood
from mutilated animals occasionally we
found what looked like sedatives we used
gas chromatography mass spectrometry we
used liquid chromatography mass
spectrometry we used inductive coupled
plasma mass spectrometry determine
elemental analysis so we threw the
kitchen sink in terms of analytical
capability at what was in these animals
following necropsy we also did histology
analysis and we determined that yes
sharp instruments were used but some of
the time we used we were able to
document
um
compounds like oxandole succinal choline
which are sedatives so that made us
suspicious on on other occasions
including investigations up in montana
uh we were able to locate
um you know 10 gauge needles that were
found under uh the
some of these animals in other cases we
were able to find medical paraphernalia
associated with exsanguinating an animal
in other words hooking up an animal to
a large gage needle and removing all the
blood from the animal so we began to get
suspicious as time went on that there
was a pattern associated with some of
these cases so we we put out the
hypothesis
that you know maybe this was part of
a a case of
um you know applying sedatives to the
animals um and then investigating these
animals for the spread of say an
infectious disease
organism and you know a lot of these
infectious disease could be um through
the western herds in the united states
uh we we we investigated or we put out
the hypothesis that maybe
some of these infectious proteins called
prions
might have been the source of concern
as they were sort of exploding in the
united kingdom and europe in the 1990s
and killing a lot of people who are
eating contaminated meat so there might
have been a small
very very small program all you need is
a couple of trained veterinarians a
couple of skill surgeons um a couple of
helicopters a very small program in
other words that could monitor
um the spread of an infectious organism
through the cattle
in the wild in the western part of the
united states
why would you want to do that and rather
than going to
uh say slaughterhouses and abattoirs and
sampling from there
the answer to that is you would not get
the same amount of data
from sampling avatars and
slaughterhouses as you would by
flying in at night and you know uh
basically sampling animals within you
know several hundred miles uh if you
were trying to track the spread of an
infectious organism
prion is what one can one uh
one an infectious protein that was
responsible for
you know
destruction of millions of animals in
the united kingdom and europe and it was
a source of huge amounts of concern in
the uh in the united states in the 1990s
as especially the
um you know the fda on the the usda
the the
united states department of agriculture
um
we're very concerned about the the
spread of this so um that was one
hypothesis we came up with why did we
come up with this because we use
forensic analysis to determine that
somebody was using sharp instruments on
these animals to cut them open
we found that unequivocally from the
histopathology analysis and then we
found all of these suspicious compounds
through
standard forensic analytical uh
chemistry and and we also found evidence
of medical hardware
underneath an unassociated with a small
number of these animals so um
you know that we put out this hypothesis
and again it's these published papers
are on the news website if people want
to take a look at them
let me add this kurt uh please to boil
that down so column's
hypothesis was there are two levels of
mutilators uh mystery mutilators there's
the original one that's been carrying
this out for decades under the cover of
night carving up animals with surgical
precision removing the same sort of
parts
not leaving behind certain compounds not
leaving behind medical instruments it's
a complete mystery how it's carried out
there were some cases where high heat
instrumentation was used in these cases
the classic mutilation stories that
we've always heard nids investigated
those and and most of the cases they
investigated did not show these kind of
telltale signs of human intervention
someone mystery mutilators have been
carrying this out for decades over a
broad
part of the united states in
other parts of the world and then later
there were an additional level of
mutilators who came in under the
umbrella of this seemingly paranormal
mystery who operated with impunity
thinking they can get away with it no
one's really going to seriously
investigate it because it's the space
people doing these mysterious
mutilations there were cases on the
ranch for example that defy explanation
i'm thinking of one in particular there
were something like 14 head of cattle
that vanished that you'd see the tracks
lead out into the snow and then the cow
was gone as if it sucked up into the sky
there were cases that the neighbors
reported of cattle that seemed to have
been dropped from the sky their legs
were broken um there were cases on the
ranch one in particular that we wrote
about in a in the hunt for the
skinwalker the rancher and his wife had
had all this bizarre activity on their
property they'd carry on they they were
really financially strapped because of
the loss of these very expensive animals
it's a sunday morning it's a bright
sunny day quiet out there in the country
they go out to tag the ears of newborn
calves they had several calves on the on
their pasture
they're going to tag the ears which is a
process that the ranchers do to identify
these animals there's a calf and it's
mom 50 yards from the house where they
live that's the first one they come to
they tag the ear this newborn calf they
move off across the property again very
quiet there's no obstruction the weather
is calm they go off on the property
about 30 minutes or so later a dog
that's traveling with them alerts them
that something's going on so they look
back at this calf the first one that
they had
tagged and the mom the cow is
going around in circles its eyes are
bulging out it's obviously distressed
it's dragging its leg behind it
rancher and his wife go back over there
to where this this calf was this calf is
completely emaciated it is wiped out it
is stripped of all its flesh the only
thing left is bones and high there's no
blood in the animal there's no blood on
the ground
75 pounds of meat gone how did it happen
why didn't they why weren't they able to
hear it could a predator what what
predator comes in and
wipes out a calf
and makes no sound and leaves no blood
uh nid's team brought in a tracker
professional tracker to look for animal
tracks
to look for human tracks vehicle tracks
didn't find it they took samples of that
set it to two different pathology labs
the uh the
investigators figured out that two
different cutting instruments had been
used something like a heavy machete to
whack off chunks of flesh and then
something with the scalpel type
precision
how does that happen how does it happen
in broad daylight that nobody sees it
now
is that the mystery government
mutilators a team of commandos comes in
completely undetected and wipes out this
cap and leaves it there for people to
find um or is it something else i i
think it's probably something else maybe
column wants to add to that
well
you know that it goes back to
the idea that
it's very very easy for a team of people
who are
sampling carrying out these illegal
killings of cattle
sampling at night because you've got two
things that are working for you
and that is
number one
you've got this whole aura of ufos
associated with cattle mutilations and
no respectable veterinarian or no
respectable police officer wants to have
anything to do with this if there's even
the taint of quote-unquote aliens
associated uh with it and the second
thing that you have going for you is you
have the decomposition process
especially in summer i mean the
decomposition process of a
cow is extremely rapid because their
entire uh rumen which is the second or
third stomach that they have is loaded
with bacteria and microorganisms which
actually chew up uh the entire flesh
extremely quickly so all you have to do
if you are actually sampling an animal
on the ground is wait for 48 hours and
pretty well all of the evidence is gone
by means of mother nature you don't even
have to cover up your tracks all you
have to do is is take your samples and
and get out of there but you know what
george is saying is absolutely true
there were a small number of these cases
that were where
we documented and they were obviously
not the uh you know the perpetrators
that i've been talking about there was
something else going on um and we we
documented cases in northern california
that were they also had this weird um
effect that that george described of the
case on in utah
we documented other cases in california
too so
there was a small component of these
that had this
um bizarre
paranormal taint
to it and then you had this other
large number of cases
that were consistent with some kind of a
sampling exercise and you know it's the
same kind of thing as the ufo phenomenon
uh the united states government used the
ufo phenomenon as a way of covering up
their their special access programs so
maybe some sort of small contractor was
using the ufo lord associated with with
cat mutilations to also cover up their
tracks
you know same kind of thing there are
levels of deception
involved in investigating these kinds of
anomalies